(mid-tempo reserved music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Christof Koch,
who is the Lois and Victor Troendle
Professor of Cognitive and
Behavioral Biology at Caltech,
and the author most recently
of The Quest for Consciousness.
He is on the Berkeley campus
to give the Foerster lecture
on the Immortality of the Soul.
Christof, welcome to Berkeley.
- Good morning, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- In the Midwest, in Kansas
City, believe it or not.
- Surprising, surprising.
How did you happen to be
in America for your birth?
- I talk like our governor does.
- (laughs) That's right!
- My parents were diplomats
with the German state department,
so they happened to be in Kansas City
because there turned out
to be lots of Germans there
who emigrated there after the war.
So, I moved around.
I have a French Baccalaureate,
and then I lived in Morocco,
and in Holland, and in Canada.
- Mm hmm, so, a citizen of the world.
Looking back, how do
you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well, since I moved every three years,
I didn't have so many, you know,
it's difficult to acquire
long-term friends,
so I mean everything was,
we are a very tight family.
So, all my intellectual upbringing,
and my desires, my passions,
I have from my parents.
- And when did you get the
science bug, so to speak?
What led you into science?
- Well, I mean, from eight, nine,
or 10 I wanted to be a zoologist.
I wanted to be a zoo
director and a zoologist.
And then somewhere at age 13 or 14,
I wanted to be a physicist,
and then I studied physics.
I guess it shows you the
importance of role models.
I grew up reading books
about you know Einstein,
and Heisenberg, and Planck,
and all these physicists,
and that was terribly influential for me.
And then when I decided upon a university,
well, I never really made
a conscious decision,
it was always clear I was gonna go
to a university and study physics.
That's what I did.
- And when one looks at your
degrees and the subject matter,
you really have covered
the gambit of the sciences.
You have a French baccalaureate,
you studied physics and
philosophy at Tubingen in Germany,
and master in physics
and a Ph.D. in nonlinear
information processing
in the dendritic trees
of arbitrary geometry.
- That's correct.
- (laughs) So, science
has come to you easily?
I mean there was a kind of
a natural coming together
with these different subjects,
or did one set of problems lead you
to another set of problems?
- Well, both, I mean I
always wanted to be a,
I mean at least from a very early age on.
I love science, I love the
process of doing science.
If I could, I'd like to know everything
there is about the world.
But of course, you have to realize
as you get older you have to concentrate
on one particular aspect of it.
And so I chose to
concentrate on the brain,
how the brain processes information,
in what way is it like a computer,
in what way is it
different from a computer.
And then over the last 20 years,
on the problem of consciousness,
possibly influenced because of
the many philosophers I read.
- Now help us understand,
is it fair to call you a
neurobiologist, is that?
- [Christof] Yes.
- Yes, help us understand
the skills and temperament
required to do that kind of work,
before we talk about the work.
- I mean it's different
from being a physicist.
So in some parts of
science, like in physics,
there are a few deep principles,
like general relativity,
or like electrodynamics,
and then you can use a few principles
to explain a large number
of facts in the universe,
like the cosmos and its evolution,
and how particles move inside the cosmos,
and how planets act, and
things like, and you know,
why if I drop my keys,
why do they fall to the floor, et cetera.
Biology's a very different character.
Biology, there are very
few common principles,
except maybe the theory of evolution.
There's a gigantic,
a gargantuan number of facts
that you have to know
and have to assemble,
so you really have to be
in the field a long time.
So, children prodigies exist
in maybe in mathematics
or in music, or maybe in some
areas of theoretical physics,
but don't exist in biology
because in biology you just have to know
a huge number of facts,
which of course takes time to acquire,
because you know each biological system is
sort of an accident of evolution,
and to understand it,
you have to understand
its unique circumstances,
and how this animal's
different from this animal.
And you have to just
know molecular biology,
and biochemistry, and
neuroscience, and psychology,
and the theory of evolution.
So, it requires a much
larger number of facts
to explain any given observation.
- What about temperament?
I know at looking at your website,
that you are adventuresome,
you're a mountain climber, and so on.
Is that just you personally,
or what about the temperament
of somebody doing this work
that brings together so many fields?
- Well, you have to love risk,
which I guess is what
you have to love doing
if you like to climb rocks and mountains.
And you have to be in
it for the long term.
It takes a long time, you
have to be very patient,
and you have to love the process.
You have to love the process,
because the action itself
takes place over many years.
You have to fight to get
money to do the research,
the research itself is very difficult,
it's technically very demanding,
it takes long, long hours,
and then you have to
fight to get it published
and get it accepted by your peers.
And so you know, this can
take five, six, seven years
for a single experiment,
to run through this entire
life-cycle of one experiment.
And so, you really have
to be passionate about it,
and you have to be
passionate about the process,
and the rewards that are
sort of very long-term,
distant in the future.
I mean the objective of what
it's like to get tenure,
you get a good salary,
something like that.
So you have to do it
because you love the act of thinking about
and trying to understand a phenomenon,
trying to collect data,
and sift through the data,
and try to find, you know
sort the chaff from the wheat,
and do things like that.
- Mm hmm, now I know that
one of your main projects
in the last few years
is covered in this book,
The Quest for Consciousness:
A Neurobiological Approach.
And what I first wanna ask you is to talk
about your collaboration
with Francis Crick,
because I know that the two of you working
over a number of years came to define
a kind of intellectual frame.
But talk a little about
that intellectual process
between the two of you.
- And so Francis, has I
guess, the way he works,
he never had a lab,
he never worked with a
large number of people
at any given point in time.
He worked with one or two people,
most famously, of course, was Jim Watson,
and then also with Sydney
Brenner, with Graeme Mitchison.
And so we worked for
close to almost 20 years.
When I moved from MIT to Caltech in '86
we started to interact and
we met on a monthly basis
to talk about the brain.
And then in 1989,
we started becoming very
intensely interested
because there was a certain
neurobiological discovery,
we became very interested in that
and we thought maybe this would be
one of the critical features,
a signature of consciousness in the brain.
And I think what Francis
appreciated about our interaction,
well, the energy level,
but also that you know
because he's such a well-known person,
many people didn't really
criticize any of his idea,
and he didn't like that.
He wanted to be criticized.
He was prodigious at throwing out ideas.
Some were very smart,
some were very perceptive,
some were not so, some were just crazy,
but you know, you have
this fantastic person,
this creative genius, who can
just throw out these ideas,
and he wants a sounding board to tell you,
well, this isn't gonna work,
this is really great but
this is totally silly,
and really have a give or
take over many, many hours.
I mean that was his style of working,
that you came in the morning
and from 10 o'clock till six o'clock
you would just discuss paper.
He would go through the evidence,
he would sift the data, discuss it,
look at it from different light,
reject it, have a hypothesis,
reject it again, then dinner,
and then usually after dinner
that process would continue.
He kept this up till
essentially the day he died.
- Mm hmm, and what we have here is
we're on the threshold of a revolution
in the biological sciences on the question
of how the brain works
and the biological basis of consciousness.
So what in a way this collaboration was
was the formation of a kind of theory
which could then be tested
by empirical research.
Is that fair?
Is that a fair way to look
at the article that resulted
which I guess you published
in Science and Nature,
laying out an intellectual framework?
- Yes, it's unfortunately,
it's too ambitious
to call it a theory.
It's a framework.
And there's a difference.
A theory is something much more solid
where you can make very
specific predictions,
like the theory of relativity.
This is more a framework
for approaching the problem
in a way that allows you for
a sustained research program
at the end of which you
will understand much more
about consciousness, and hopefully,
that's a hope right now, a fond hope,
that ultimately you will solve the problem
at the heart of the classical
conceived mind/body problem.
Namely, how do feelings
get into the world?
How is it that the physical system,
like your brain or my brain,
can have feelings of pain or pleasure?
Of being me?
Of being angry?
- Mm hmm, now help us understand,
I think we know what consciousness is,
or people think they do, but explain that.
Now I think you refer
to Searle's definition,
but help us kind of
understand what the it is
that you're trying to
characterize, and then find
the sources of that in
the biology of the brain.
- Yeah, John Searle you know
says that consciousness,
what you have when you wake
up in the morning you have it,
you have it all day,
and then it goes away when
you go into deep sleep,
and then in dreams, of
course, you also have it.
So, it's the most fundamental
feature of the world.
It's the way how we experience the world.
When I feel pain or feel pleasure,
I see you, or I'm angry,
or I know I'm Christof,
I know I'm gonna die,
those are all conscious sensations.
Philosophers have the term qualia,
so consciousness is made
up these different qualia.
Qualia for being angry, for seeing red,
and that is fundamentally the way,
how we experience the world.
To experience the world
means to be conscious of it.
It turns out there are many
things that I can do in my body.
In fact, most of the things I do
without having any
conscious access to them.
My digestive system works wonderful
without me knowing about it.
There're a hundred million neurons
roughly down here in your
gut, a hundred million.
We're not conscious of them.
When you run, when you climb,
when you dance, when you drive a car,
when you bike, you're
doing things effortlessly.
When you run down a mountain,
you run very quickly and you have no idea
how you're doing it, you're
doing it unconsciously.
When I talk, it's not
that there's a person,
a Christof, in my head
who sort of puts these words together,
and then in German or English,
in the verb and the
adjective and sends it out.
No, I have a vague idea
and the next thing,
I hear these words coming out of my mouth.
So, we know there are many things,
in fact, the majority
of things in my brain,
I don't have conscious access to.
Certain things I do have
conscious access to.
Where's the difference?
How is this possible?
- And you actually refer to
this as kind of a zombie effect,
namely, not the consciousness,
but these things that we do automatically.
- Yeah, so we have all these zombies
that we use all the time.
In fact, life wouldn't be possible
without these zombie agents in our head.
And so this makes you know,
makes for an interesting research strategy
because I can now ask at
the neurological level,
at the brain level,
where's the difference
between those systems
that mediate my zombie behaviors
and those systems that
actually require consciousness?
And it's a scandal, and
Francis always felt this,
it's a scandal if science
leaves out consciousness.
You know it's less today,
but certainly 10 or 20
years ago when we started,
many scientists, probably the majority,
said, well, you know consciousness,
you've got to leave that
to the religious people,
to the philosophers,
you've got to leave that to
the you know New Age cult.
That's not something scientists can study.
But that's silly.
I mean we are conscious
and I believe it's the most
essential aspect of my life,
it's the fact that I'm a conscious being,
and if I leave that out,
then I will forever deprive science
of one of the key aspects
of the natural world.
We claim it's a natural phenomenon,
it exists not here,
but it seems to exist here,
so if science has ambition
that it wants to describe
everything in this universe,
then it has to describe consciousness.
In other words, it's just a cop-out.
Yes, it's difficult,
it's different than
trying to have a theory
for how mass is derived,
but it's nonetheless a natural phenomenon
and we should study it as scientists.
- Now, one is able to do the
experimentation now, why?
Because of all of the new technologies
that are coming on board
that are allowing us
to look at the brain?
- Yeah, I mean, we can now
do routinely in animals,
we can monitor individual nerve cells.
So you have to understand
if you wanna understand chemistry,
or if you want to understand physics,
you need to know about atoms,
and you need to know about molecules,
and you need to know how they interact.
You can't do chemistry without
knowing about molecules.
Likewise, if you wanna
understand consciousness
or perception or memory or thought,
and what happens if these
goes wrong in mental diseases,
you need to know about nerve cells,
and you need to know how they interact.
And we today, in 2006,
better than before in
any point in history,
we can monitor nerve cells,
we can listen to them,
we can record them,
we can stimulate them, we
can do all sorts of things,
both in animals as well as in humans.
In humans it's much more
difficult, of course.
We have brain imaging, which is cool,
but it's a very low spatial resolution.
But we have all these
tools that enable us now
to begin to monitor the brain
at the appropriate level of resolution.
And so now we think it's the time
to start having experiments,
and people are doing it,
to study the neural
basis of consciousness.
- And so the, another challenge, I guess,
is to devise the experiments,
to create reactions and
then put this together,
what we're now able to see.
Is that the name of the game here?
- Yeah, I mean this is what scientists do.
I try to do the right control,
do the correct experiment.
Which, as I mentioned before,
may take you many years
to figure out some fact
about the brain basis of consciousness.
- Is there a thumbnail sketch of the brain
that you could give a general audience,
where the most exciting points
of direction seem to be in your research?
- Wait, you want a summary, an
explanation of the brain or?
- Let me rephrase it.
It's a bad question.
In other words, basically,
so let's begin talking
about what your hypothesis is
about how the brain works at
this point of consciousness.
What are the hypotheses that help give you
an organizing sense of
how to look for things?
- Okay, so first of all,
the overall approach that we advocate
that's now, most people do this,
is to study what people abbreviate as NCC,
the neuronal correlate of consciousness.
Those are the minimal brain, the minimal
because we know your
entire brain is sufficient
to give rise to consciousness,
it does it each and every day.
But do you really need your eyes to see?
Well, I can dream.
My eyes are closed and
I perfectly well dream,
perfectly formed visual images.
I can close my eyes and I can visualize,
so I don't need my eyes.
Do I need my cerebellum?
Probably not for visual consciousness
or probably not for any consciousness.
So you can ask these question,
what are the minimal set of mechanisms
in your head that you need
in order to be conscious?
Is there a specific neurosignature,
are there specific types of neurons,
is there a particular
type of neural activity,
are there particular types of molecules,
particular types of synapses,
do they sit in a particular
part of the brain?
So you can ask this
whole set of questions,
and the name of the game is
to try to isolate those mechanisms
to really hone in, saying, okay,
these neurons in this
particular configuration.
We talk about coalition of
neurons, you have to imagine
the brain has a very,
very, very large number,
there are roughly 50 to
100 billion nerve cells,
and each one is like a little computer.
Neurons are not sort of
dumb, like a transistor.
They're very quote, smart,
they're very sophisticated,
each nerve cell, each neuron,
and you have 100 billion of them.
And consciousness may be
a coalition of neurons
You know, it's little
bit like in a democracy
when you have coalition that form,
and that assemble and then disassemble,
except the time scale is not years like
in the American electoral system,
but it's sort of fraction of a second.
And so, for a hundredth of a millisecond
you may have this coalition
of five million neurons,
and they make in code,
they may give rise to,
they may be the feeling of
darn it, I'm late today,
and then this is suppressed
because then there's this
other five million neurons,
or 10 million neurons,
who now give rise to the oh,
I see my daughter over there,
and you know then the fact that I'm late,
you know I forget that,
you know and I become
conscious of my daughter,
and those neurons in the brain
that represent my daughter
fire and they are,
well, this now depends exactly
on your philosophical predisposition.
Some people say the firing
of these neurons is
identical to consciousness.
Some people say, well, it
correlates with consciousness,
those are the things that we don't know.
But what we try to do empirically
where are those neurons?
Can you track them?
Can you catch a brief picture of them
using some fancy imaging techniques?
Can you influence them?
Can you move from,
scientists, very often,
we can just observe.
So, for example, a
function of brain imaging,
I put you in a magnet,
I show you faces, and I see
every time you look at a face,
this part of the brain lights up.
People do that routinely.
So that's observation, that's correlation.
What I would then like to do,
I would like to move to
causation, where I can influence.
What happens if I can
put a probe in your brain
like a neurosurgeon does
during neurosurgery,
and I can stimulate that
particular part of the brain?
Will you then see a face?
And again, we can begin
to do those experiments
quite well in animals,
and we can also do them
in certain contexts,
for example, in a neurosurgical
context with humans,
where it can actually begin
to intervene with the brain.
- And you, as a matter of your strategy,
are focusing not on all
the different senses
but really perception.
Tell us about that choice.
- Yeah, we focus on vision,
visual consciousness.
So you know,
it's a little bit like the
drunkard who lost his keys
and then looks for his
lost key where the lamp is.
These are all very,
very difficult problems,
we haven't made that much
progress over the last 2000 years,
so when you ask people consciousness,
they say, oh, you mean self-consciousness.
Yes, self-consciousness,
one aspect of consciousness,
but it's very difficult to study.
The fact that I know I'm
Christof, I know I'm a son,
I know I have children, et cetera.
That's very difficult to study empirically
because it's it's unclear
to what extent animals have consciousness.
Some probably do, like the great apes,
but it's very difficult to study that.
So, let's study a much
simpler aspect of conscience,
namely red or blue or seeing
motion or seeing a face.
We can manipulate that very well.
We can do what magicians
do since hundreds of years.
So if you go to a magic show,
you look at the magician.
The magician will make things disappear
in front of your eyes.
He does that partly by
using attention distraction.
Use a beautiful bikini-clad
assistant next to him
and you'll be distracted.
Although you're looking at him,
you're actually paying attention to her.
We can do something similar, less sexy,
but we can do something
similar in the lab.
Where we can show you things
that you routinely don't see.
They're in front of your eyes,
sometimes you see them,
sometimes you don't.
So now we can use this technique to ask,
well, in both cases there's
an image present on your eyes,
but one case you were actually
conscious of the image,
in the other case you were
not conscious of the image.
Where's the difference in your brain?
Is the area X, the consciousness
area that lights up,
that's one hypothesis.
That whenever this area lights
up, were you conscious of it?
Where is that area?
Is it a series of stages?
It's not gonna be one area, we know that.
It's gonna be a series of
areas, probably distributed,
that have different properties.
So, we can do this in a magnet,
we can put you in a magnet and
we can show you these images
that you see sometimes
and sometimes you don't,
and we can study that.
And you can also do this in a monkey,
or you can do it in a mouse.
So, vision has the
advantage, visual perception,
and we can manipulate your visual percept
very precisely in space and time.
We can't do that as well as for pain,
well, it's also very
difficult to recruit people
to do pain experiments.
- [Harry] (chuckles) Yeah, right.
- It's very easy to recruit
them to look at a monitor,
and you know we pay 'em
twenty bucks to do that.
And so, it's a tactical reason
why we focus on visual perception.
- And some of these experiments
play with, for example,
when you, these coalitions are often
in competition, basically, is that?
- Yes, just like, again, that's
where I think the election
or democratic analogy or
metaphor is very appropriate.
You have all these neurons in your head
and they constantly compete.
They excite and inhibit each other
At any given point in time,
there's only one dominant coalition.
That reflects the character
of your consciousness.
By and large, you're only
conscious of one or two things
at any given point in time.
You can shift rapidly within
a fraction of a second,
but at any given point in time
you're usually only conscious of,
let's say, one or two things.
And so, when you're
conscious of one thing,
something else is suppressed.
And you can see that, for example,
the phenomenon of tip of the tongue,
when you say, oh, what's
that name, what's that name?
You know and then you do something else
and 20 minutes later,
it pops into your mind.
That's exactly a case where
the coalition of neurons
that represent the name
of this acquaintance
you're trying to recall is
suppressed by something else.
Yeah, so, you wanna track this, and again,
we have experiments in the lab
where we can do this very well.
We have two different images,
and for example, we put
one image in one eye
and a different image in the
other eye and they compete.
You only see one image at
any given point in time,
although they're both present.
Let's say you put a picture
of you know George Bush here
and you put a picture of John Kerry here.
You will only see one of them at a time.
It's called binocular rivalry.
For 10 seconds you may see Bush,
and then there's a transition,
you see Kerry for a couple of seconds,
then again changes to Bush.
So, you have the two images
and the underlying neurons
that represent them, they
compete for attention.
So, you can use this paradigm to, again,
to study the footprints of
consciousness in the brain,
in a human brain or in a monkey brain.
- Right, and do the combination
of these experiments
over time pursuing this framework,
do you hope it will lead
to a general picture
that answers some of
these specific questions?
- Yes, of course, of course.
When there's aid or not
it's really no alternative.
All right, consciousness
is a difficult problem.
We as humanity have thought about it,
in the Western tradition at least since
at least since 2,300 years.
And the only way to approach
it is in an empirical manner,
step by step.
You try to discover something
about the material basis.
Ultimately, of course, you
need a theory of consciousness.
You need not just the neural correlates
but you wanna understand
what type of systems,
and at what conditions
have conscious sensation.
Because I'd like to know, for example,
in principle I'd like to know
what about a young baby
that doesn't speak?
What about a fetus?
What about the patient who is in coma
or who has a persistent
vegetative syndrome,
like Terri Schiavo?
You know, I'd like to have a measure,
a real theoretical understanding,
is she or is she not conscious?
What about a monkey?
What about a dog?
What about a squid?
What about a fly?
Right now, we don't have a good theory,
for example, for insects.
You know we accord consciousness
really to the degree
that other people are like us.
And you can go back in history, right.
People, you know even the
Greeks, they first thought,
well, you know the really only true humans
are other Greeks, right?
The other one were barbarous,
they were barbarous.
And we decided slowly, the
last couple of thousand years,
we decided well, we'll extend
this privilege of being
real humans to women and to other people,
and to other races.
And now we're beginning to
extend this magic circle
to other animals.
That if a monkey or a dog,
yes, they don't speak,
they're a little more furry,
they look a little bit different,
but their brain is very
similar to you or mine.
If I give you a little bit
of monkey brain or dog brain,
a little bit of human brain,
it takes an expert to
really tell the difference.
The behavior is very similar,
appropriately measured.
So if a dog's in pain,
that behavior is not that
dissimilar to when you're in pain.
You know, it yelps, it
has a high motor activity,
you know it wants to run away and hide,
similar things to you do.
Evolutionary continuity,
all those reasons,
suggest that these animals
are also conscious.
They're not as conscious as we are,
they don't know about Macintosh computers
or things like that,
but they certainly seem to have
all the basic conscious
sensation of pain and pleasure,
and they can be depressed,
they can be happy,
they can be excited.
Now where does it end?
What about a squid, and what about a bee?
A bee is a very complicated organism.
So, finally, we need a theory
that tells us which organism,
including which artificial organism.
At what point can you say, for example,
say if ever, that the
internet is conscious?
What about a robot, what about a computer?
So, we're finding what we need is a theory
that tells us which system,
under what condition,
will be conscious.
- Now what about this notion
that one had in earlier periods of time,
of the notion of a little man, basic--
- [Christof] Homunculus.
- Yeah, homunculus in your head.
I mean, obviously, there
is no little man there,
but is that a kind of hypothesis
that one can work with,
and do you still try to use to,
'cause you're really
talking about something
that moves beyond the zombie effect
where you're responding,
I believe you say,
you're responding to
your present environment,
but also it's related
to the planning area.
This is the point at
which we need some entity,
some unit, to be making choices.
- Yeah, to me, it's a very
compelling illusion, right.
We all have it.
There's a person actually
sitting in my head,
I can tell you where, he sits
here, right, roughly here.
If you have one eye, I presume
it would shift it over.
And he's looking out at the world.
We all have this homunculus
illusion, it's very compelling.
So Francis Crick argued there has to be
some neuronal basis for that
to explain this very compelling feeling,
and we have an explanation for that.
But of course, as you point
out, there is no homunculus,
it's just a series of very
congregated neural networks,
and one network, quote, is
looking at another network,
and that's being looked
at by another network,
and ultimately what you
get out of this system,
you get this feeling
that there is a person
sitting inside my head.
But there is, of course,
no point where you can say, well, see?
That area, that's Christof, right.
That it's gonna be,
like most other things,
a collection of neurons
that do this process
that ultimately give rise
to this mysterious feeling,
there's a person inside my head.
- So I guess one of the
images that struck me
in the essay was the notion
of that there are elements
of the brain that are
like a movie essentially,
or at least that,
could you help us understand that?
That in other words,
motion may come out of a series of images
that are in your brain,
and presumably the images are an output
of these coalitions of neurons?
Help us get a handle on that.
- All right, there's this hypothesis,
is consciousness like a river,
or is it more like a movie
where you have, well, we all
know we have the illusion
of seeing life on the screen,
but in fact, if you look closely,
you know there are 24 frames a second,
or 72 frames a second,
and so you have a frame like this,
the next frame like this,
the next frame like this.
But what you see, of
course, is smooth motion.
So psychologists have asked
this question since a long time,
there's now some more evidence for it,
that perception is actually discrete,
it's actually organized
in discrete snapshots.
Each snapshot may be 30
milliseconds, 15 milliseconds,
100 milliseconds, so a
small fraction of a second,
and each snapshot is a
little bit like frozen.
So it's like a drawing that
you make of a runner like this.
You know, clearly this drawing implies
you know the person's moving forward
but the drawing itself is stationary,
but it come with the drawing,
the stationary drawing comes
with the sense of motion.
And there is this area
that scientists have identified called MT,
you have it on both sides of your brain,
or sometimes called V5.
It seems to be involved in motion.
If you stimulate it, there's
a sense of motion in animals.
If you lose it, you lose
the sense of motion.
And the hypothesis is that these neurons
in this part of the brain
that they encode motion in
a series of these snapshots.
And usually, just like in a
movie, you're fooled by it.
Although these are discrete snapshots,
the world looks continuous.
But there may be a rare condition,
and the neurologist
Oliver Sacks has described
one of these when, for example,
he himself has had this
condition under migraines,
where this mechanism breaks down.
And he describes this
very vividly himself,
and also the experiences
of some of his patients.
When he sees, he says the world
appears shattered, atomized.
What you see, I see the
nurse comes towards me
and she's in these discrete stills.
I don't see her smooth anymore.
It's like a movie run too slow.
And so this well may be
a manifestation of something
that's more general,
that maybe all of our
perception is actually illusory,
this smoothing, changing
river of consciousness
may actually be illusory in the sense
that it is actually a
discontinuous set of snapshots
but we don't experience it as such.
It would be another example
of this perfect con job that's perception.
There're so many things
that are not really the way they seem,
but our brain suggests them,
and our brain is very good at that.
- And it the case that
the brain will often
substitute information where
there is no information?
I mean will it fill in frames, yeah?
- Yes, well, for instance, the blind spot.
I mean if I close my eye, we well know,
at least since the 15th century,
there's a you know, you can
find it here, roughly here.
When there's a spot called the blind spot,
when there's no information,
there are no photoreceptors there
because in that location
the wires leave the eye.
And so at that location
there's no visual information.
It's like you take your camera,
your video camera, your consumer camera,
and some of the pixels are black,
they would always be black.
You would immediately send it back, right.
Well, why don't we complain?
Well, it turns out there's
a mechanism in the brain
that compensates for.
So, I don't see a hole.
I sort of have to test it,
but I think, well, okay,
somewhere around here
my finger disappears.
Again, it's a con job.
It fills in the information.
There's no information, but
it cleverly fills it in.
There are many, many cases like that
where the brain fills it in,
usually using appropriate stimuli
because it learned over
the course of evolution,
it makes sense, on average it makes sense.
But if you test it carefully,
you can see there is a lot
of this filling constantly going on.
And even at the high level,
at the cognitive level,
I constantly make implicit
assumptions about people,
about their behavior,
and I do it all the time unconsciously.
It's just another example
of the brain filling in
and predicting things that are missing
or predicting things into the future.
That's what our brain does.
- Now in addition to
designing experiments,
I guess pathologies and disease
are a fruitful place to look.
And this comes out in Oliver Sacks' essays
in the New York Review.
Talk a little about that
because they offer the possibility
of the breakdown of the systems,
and then a testing of the
map of the mind at that time.
- Yeah, so probably one of
the most richest sources,
the most fertile sources of information
about consciousness is of course is humans
because we can talk about it.
And so there, you have to go to the clinic
where you see a lot of
sometimes bizarre conditions
but that tell you a lot
about consciousness.
So, for example, for the prosopagnosia,
you're unable to see a face.
So the patient says, well, I can see,
and they're different forms of it,
I can see your mouth,
I can see your eyes,
and I can see your ears,
so I know there's got to be a face
because I know intellectually
they go together,
but I actually don't see it.
And it turns out you have a particular,
very often a particular part
of the brain is destroyed.
That tells us a really important point.
That tells us consciousness,
at least for faces, is localized.
It's not global, distributed,
holistic, gestalt-like,
as a lot of people think.
In this case, there's
actually discrete foci.
There are a bunch of
neurons that code for faces,
that code for the conscious
perception of the faces.
If you lose them, you're
unable to see faces.
You can still think about them abstractly
but you can't see a face anymore.
Another very important discovery was done
at Caltech by Roger Sperry,
based again on the brains
that don't work very well,
namely epileptic seizures.
And sometimes to prevent seizures
from going from a small attack,
from a so-called focal attack,
into a grand mal attack you
know where people thrash around,
you cut 200 million fibers connecting
the left brain and the right brain.
And then what they then realized
that you actually have two consciousness,
two minds in one skull.
You have the left hemisphere,
usually by and large that talks,
that's usually the
linguistic competent one.
The right one can sing,
the right one can grunt,
the right one can answer simple questions,
but it's not very sophisticated,
but it seems to be conscious.
So, now you really have the dilemma,
you have two people, in a sense,
two conscious entity
inside this one skull.
It's a really interesting discovery.
We work with patients,
we work with a neurosurgeon,
Dr. Fried at UCLA,
again with epileptic patients,
where we can record for many days
from individual nerve cells,
something you can never
do in a human otherwise.
You can discover very
interesting nerve cells
in the brain of these patient.
So, again, the clinic has been
one of the most fecund
sources of information
about the brain and about consciousness.
- And ultimately, the insights
that you draw on perception
potentially could lead to insights
that are actually relevant
for the other areas of consciousness,
smell, and so forth.
Is that the hope here?
- Yeah, just like in
molecular biology, Harry,
it's just like in molecular biology,
where people argued early on,
like Max Delbruck, for example, who said,
well, let's study phages,
phages are these viruses
that prey upon bacteria,
and let's study the genetics there.
And some people argued well,
that's so remote from human genetics,
it's not gonna tell us anything.
Well, it turned out it's
the same mechanisms,
RNA, DNA, and proteins,
the same mechanism.
So, here the assumption
is, it's a hypothesis,
maybe wrong, the hypothesis is
that consciousness is
something biological,
it evolved we don't know when,
100 to 200 million years ago, who knows,
but it's something that
probably first came
with consciousness for simple
things like pain and pleasure,
then evolution discovered
it's a great thing.
We think the function is to plan.
And then it probably
used the same mechanism
for visual consciousness,
for olfactory consciousness,
and later on in more complicated animals
like great apes, and like dolphins,
and ultimately like us.
Also for self-consciousness,
knowing who I am and projecting myself
in the future of going
through different scenarios.
If there's an earthquake here,
which door did I come in?
Which door should I try to egress?
So yes, there is a common,
that all these different forms
of consciousness have something common.
They have this subjective
consciousness common,
but they also will have or
may have something common
at the neurobiological base.
They're all caused by a similar
set of neuro-mechanisms.
That's the hypothesis.
- As I listen to you,
I wanna understand how you are confident
amidst this complexity
that you're describing
because there's an
interesting synergy here.
You're saying you wanna focus
on a piece of the action,
but the level of complexity is striking
because it's not just perception
ultimately you're talking about,
you're talking about past
and present, and so on.
Talk a little about that
because that must bring the excitement
that you get in mountain climbing.
Is there any comparability there?
- Well, in a sense it's daunting,
I mean you know it's
just like in climbing.
What do you do when you
have a difficult climb?
You don't think about the
20 pitches ahead of you
that are gonna take
you, you know 12 hours.
You just think, right
now I'm on this pitch
and this is the cracks that's coming out.
And you totally empty your mind,
you just try to solve this problem.
The same thing here.
If you think about the
brain, it's so daunting.
I mean right now there are probably only
around 50,000 neuroscientists
on the planet studying,
50,000 people study the brain.
Each day you know, each week
there's almost a new journal
in neuroscience and
related fields that appear.
So, you can be totally daunted by it.
So you have to focus and
believe that ultimately,
maybe similar to replication
and DNA and RNA translation et cetera,
there's a common, there
is a simple mechanism
at the root of consciousness
that we, I mean humans,
are able to understand.
There's no guarantee, right.
It may well be that
consciousness requires a brain,
you know even in principle
beyond our brain.
I mean some philosophers made the argument
well, what chance does an ant have
of understanding relativity?
There's nothing fundamentally
it couldn't understand,
but it just doesn't have
the cognitive operators.
Likewise, we may not have
the cognitive operators
to study consciousness.
I don't like the argument,
of course, it's defeatist.
I don't like it at all,
I tend to be optimist.
And I know for sure, the only
way we will ever solve it is
by trying to pursue this empirical.
Also, there's really no sane alternative.
- I know that people like Searle believe
that we're on the edge
of finding these answers,
that there's a real revolution,
and the next big questions are here
and they will be you know answered
in some reasonable timeframe.
Why is this, that it's all
coming together right now?
Is it that these various
disciplines are coming together?
I mean, just looking at
your own academic career
and your training, that
that is all coming together
among a community of scientists,
but also with technology
that can deliver things--
- Yes, fundamentally,
like always in science,
what's driving this is
our instrumental ability,
technology, that we can manipulate,
we can study the brain at
an unprecedented detail
in the resolution, we
can begin to manipulate.
That really makes all of this possible.
Otherwise we would just be
sitting around and speculating.
So, that's the biggest
driver of all of this.
And then yeah, the belief,
there's a convergence,
there's a meeting now each year
where philosophers, and
psychologists, and neuroscientists
come together, many hundreds of them,
and talk about consciousness.
So, there is this great excitement
that we are on the verge or
we're in this revolution,
this is gonna be one of the golden ages
that people talk about
in future histories,
and we're well on the way to understand.
Now of course, one has to admit
we may be fooling ourselves.
You know, of course, it's
always better to believe
that you're gonna solve the problem
than to say, oh, darn, I'm
not gonna solve it anyhow.
That's not how you do progress, right?
So, you could also consider
this as a form of self-hypnosis.
Right now, there's no question
we're making unprecedented progress.
We are beginning to intervene, also,
in a therapeutical context
with the human brain as never before.
So right now, everything
looks very positive.
There's no question we will find
the neuronal correlates of consciousness.
There's very little doubt about that,
assuming you know no major
catastrophe in funding,
or other things.
The big question is what a
final theory of consciousness
will look like, and will it
really explain everything?
Because some people say,
well, you know this is
all very interesting.
So I'm willing to believe in 50th time
we know that if I feel red
and these neurons fire this way,
and if I feel pain,
then those neurons fire,
but so what?
That really doesn't explain the feeling.
And then people made very
similar analogies with life.
They said, well, you
know you're gonna tell me
it's all molecules and you
know organic chemistry,
but that really doesn't explain life.
There's something magic about life.
But of course, we discovered
life is you know metabolism,
and heritability, et cetera.
And so likewise here,
we have to see how far can
we push the explanation,
and will we finally have
a satisfactory explanation
of why certain types
of systems namely ask,
some of the times, not
when we're in a deep sleep,
not when we're in a
coma, have these states.
And that's the open question.
- Are there some subset of questions
that are very important in the short term
in this kind of long-term project
that we hope to find the answers to,
that will be a piece of this?
- Yeah, so that's why we focus on,
people have criticized us focusing on
the neural correlates of consciousness.
And to see, well, you know, that I mean,
that that doesn't really
explain consciousness.
If you know these neurons
are critical, so what?
Well, A, that's something,
empirical project,
that everybody can agree
that we can actually do today
with today's technology,
and just like knowing the
molecular correlates of heredity,
once Crick and Watson solved
you know the double helix,
most of the problems were clear.
Now it's probably not gonna be
of this character for consciousness,
but it once and again shows
that structure follows function,
particularly in biological system.
And once you know the structure,
you're probably a huge step forward
to understanding its function.
You can also track then that structure,
you can track in diseased people,
as I mentioned, in babies,
you can track what happens,
you've got schizophrenia, autism, or ADHD.
You can track it in animals,
so this will be a huge step forward.
It'll not be a final
theory of consciousness,
but it will be a gigantic step forward
on the road to final resolution
of this mind/body problem.
Now of course, there are some philosophers
who think this can never be done.
All right, there are some philosophers,
David Chalmers for one,
who argue there's the hard
problem, the easy problem.
That we scientists deal
with the easy problem.
He doesn't mean easy
in the practical sense.
He says a easy problem will
take you hundreds of years
to figure it out, the mechanism,
you know this neuron
activating that neurons,
inhibiting that neurons,
but he said forever we'll
be reduced to just saying
well, finally it's just a list
of bunch of material problems
you can make in the brain,
and over here you have you know things
like blue, and pain, and
being self-conscious,
but how they link will forever elude us.
But of course, many
philosophers have before
made the argument you
know we shall never know
what the stars are made out of,
we shall never know what life is.
And so I'm very skeptical
when philosophers tell me
this is something in
principle we can never know.
We'll have to see.
- What do you think will be
the implications of this,
if you can come up with an answer?
In other words, does it have an impact
on the treatment of disease?
Does it have an impact on who we are,
and understanding our
place in the universe?
- Yes, yes, yes.
Well, certainly there's no question
it'll have an impact on disease,
and understanding things
like autism, schizophrenia.
But more even longer term,
whatever the understanding will be
you see, we grew up with
a picture in our history,
in our culture, that we grew very fond of.
And it remains to be seen
to what extent this picture
you know of people independent
actor having free will,
and a soul, and all of that
corresponds to actual reality.
And so we have to see how it pans out.
Do we really know what we are
and what's our place in the
universe, and are we unique?
Is consciousness unique to us?
What about animals?
Right now we treat animals beastly, right?
If you look at the way
the animals are raised
and kept under horrible
conditions for us to eat 'em,
is that really justifiable, really?
I don't think it is.
And so once we realize,
once we extend this magic
circle of consciousness,
once we're really compassionate
about other creatures
that can actually suffer,
and have a true understanding of that,
and at the same time
realize that certain people
cannot suffer anymore,
that a patient in PVS,
in persistent vegetative
syndrome like Terri Schiavo,
as far as we can tell from
the best medical evidence,
there isn't anything to
suffer anymore, right.
The person isn't dead because
the body's still alive,
but there's no consciousness whatsoever.
So, you could argue a person
like that should be extended less.
It's sort of on the
level of consciousness,
much, much less conscious
than any of our cats and dogs,
and pigs and cattle and veal
that we treat horribly, right.
So, all of this understanding will surely
or is gonna impact the way
we deal, we treat each other
and we treat the other
creatures in the world.
And then of course, the question
should we create other conscious
entities, like computers?
Is it a good thing?
Will we increase the amount
of suffering in the world?
Should we do this?
Under what conditions should we do this?
- How does this work
affect whatever religious
or spiritual values you hold, does it?
- Yeah, of course, I think a lot about it.
I was raised as a Roman Catholic
and I think a lot about it.
To what extent is this,
certainly it's difficult to reconcile some
of these ideas with the
classical Roman Catholic doctrine
of a freely independent actor.
All right, this relates to the question
we haven't talked about,
to the question of free will and volition.
But neuroscience, of
course, like all of science,
throws some doubts on that,
some quote, water on the idea
that I can really truly
act like the unmoved mover,
the uncaused cause, right.
Because how would that be if
I can truly act independent?
That means that there's something happens
without there being any
something happening before,
and how's that supposed
to work in real life?
So, those are issues I'm profoundly
and passionately
interested in to reconcile,
to come to a single
understanding of everything
in the universe, including
things outside the universe.
- Looking to the future,
if you had to advise
students about how to prepare
for the future in this field,
what advice would you give them?
I mean obviously they need to learn
this array of scientific
skills that you require,
but what about also humanistic
values and education
with regard to dealing with this,
once we come up with
some of these answers?
- Well, I mean what I tell people
who ask me what is they
want to do is study physics,
study math, study biology,
study the basic sciences,
be compassionate and leave
the world a better place.
There really isn't much else to say.
- (chuckles) And then finally,
what about for the public,
what is the best way to
follow this revolution?
They're obviously not gonna go back
and get graduate degrees, and so on,
but do you have some
markers that people should--
- [Christof] Well, they can read my book.
- (laughs) yeah, yeah, right,
we'll show it again, right.
- Well I mean there are now many journals,
for example, Scientific
American just started
a journal called Mind last year.
Together with the normal
Scientific American,
they have this second journal,
Scientific American Mind,
that's just dedicated to
you know the dissemination
of a lot of these ideas.
So there are many books being
written, some very good books.
John Searle has written
a wonderful little primer
on consciousness and the mind.
So, there are a number of excellent books
that are now available
for the general public
to inform themselves.
The information's all there,
I mean they, it's not,
you have to work at it.
That's not surprising.
Consciousness is a very puzzling thing
and it you know can't be reduced
to a single sound bite, right.
I mean If you ask me what's consciousness
in 30 seconds or less,
you know it's difficult to answer that.
But there are some
wonderful books available
that describe the current
state of knowledge,
incomplete as it is, for general public.
- I'm curious, looking back at
the trajectory of your life,
are there some certain factors
that have brought you to
this focus in your life?
I mean does it all come
together, in a way, in this,
or is it primarily the science education
that has led you here?
- No, it's, well, I mean,
life is always a series of accidents
and then some more profound
current that tug you,
that pull you along in
a certain direction.
So I've always had, probably
because of the way my parents
raised me in a very religious setting,
always thought a lot about some
of these more fundamental
problems about time,
about eternity, about life before death,
and life after death.
But it's always puzzled me
that people are much more
obsessed about life after death
than life before death, right.
Isn't it strange?
People are really,
particularly in the
context of consciousness.
They rarely ask, well,
what does it tell you
about life before birth?
Where was I before I
came into this planet?
They're always obsessed
about what happens after they go out.
Anyhow, no but, so that
certainly had a large influence,
you know thinking about
these big problems,
and I discovered, I learned
that the only way we can answer
these problems in any satisfactory
way is by doing science.
I mean, it's great to do philosophy,
you can think about it,
everybody should do it,
but ultimately you
can't prove any of that.
And so the only sure
touchstone we have seems to me
this empirical knowledge.
The rest, we just have
to believe something.
- Well, Christof, on that note,
I wanna thank you for sharing
your intellectual odyssey,
and also for being patient with us
for trying to get into this,
the complexity that you're working on.
I wanna show the audience your book again,
The Quest for Consciousness,
which I recommend highly.
And I wanna thank you very
much for being here today.
- Thank you very much,
Harry. It was a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(mid-tempo reserved music)